Um,
Thursday I gave the world's most
condensed lecture about the constitution.
Um,
and I mentioned three controversies that
represented long standing concerns in
Revolutionary America,
the question of representation,
the problem of slavery,
and then the question of a
national executive so that
that really boils down to
the problem of investing power in one man.
Now I did manage to discuss all three of
those things briefly before the end of
the lecture. Um, I did not have
time to discuss one last issue,
which I do want to talk about here before
I go into the real topic of today's
lecture. Um, I just ran out of time and
it actually combines two of those issues.
It's the combination of the problem of
representation and the problem of slavery.
Um, and it's something you've all
studied in high school, I am sure.
And that is the three fifths
compromise. Um, and in a sentence,
the three fist compromise is the
decision to count three fifths of a state
slaves and apportioning representatives,
presidential electors and direct taxes.
So obviously by doing that,
I mean that is a compromise of sorts.
It is trying to grapple with the
problem of slavery and the question of
representation,
but obviously that's a compromise that
bolsters southern political power.
Now the, the great historian of
slavery, Yale professor and Meredith,
David,
Brian Davis has this little
calculation associated with this issue.
Um, Davis writes that in
the continental congress,
there had been five states in which
slavery was a major institution.
So the southern states in the continental
congress had about 38% of the seats in
that Congress because of
the three fist compromise.
When the first US Congress opened
under the new constitution,
seven states now had 45%
of the seats in the house.
So 38 to 45 mins,
a significant slide.
Now that doesn't stay in grained that
way because population increases in the
north and things change over time.
But certainly that's one way in which
you can see the impact of that three
fifths compromise
now in a way that compromise. That's
a great segue into my lecture today.
Um,
it's a great example of the larger dynamic
of the period that we're focusing on
here towards the end of the course.
Because as we've been looking at
in the constitutional convention,
as we're going to see today when we're
looking at at ratification at the heart
of the political developments that we're
looking at in this period is compromise,
compromise between north and south
compromise between big states and small
states.
Compromise between people who want to
centralize power and people who want
strong state governments.
So basically what we're looking at in
this period is Americans deciding where
and how to invest power.
Obviously a highly charged decision
that would have been impossible to make
without a string of compromises.
And in a way,
as we're going to be discussing today,
this is sort of a fundamental question
at the heart of the revolution and its
immediate aftermath.
Where should the nation invest power?
Where does power go?
So in a way,
if you look back to the beginning of
the course, think about the revolution,
think about some of the central issues.
You could say that the revolution
certainly was about power, right?
It was a rebellion against what
many perceived as tyrannical power.
And that means a lot of things.
But to sum that all up in a sentence,
you could say that.
You could say that the 17th seventies
and then the 1780s show Americans trying
to figure out how to rebalance
and reorganize power,
the power of state,
you know,
they strip away the British administration
and now they have to figure out where
else to place power and how to balance it.
And we've seen the articles of
confederation and now the constitution,
which is again,
part of this ongoing dialogue trying to
figure out the balance of power and all
sorts of different ways.
And it's no wonder if you think about
what I've already just talked about as far
as the constitution is concerned,
it's no wonder that it demanded a string
of difficult and often experimental
compromises creating the constitution.
And this we'll see today ratifying the
constitution was a difficult process.
We, we tend to think of the outcome
and we don't think of the process.
And I'm always reminded of this fact when
I read an exchange of letters between
Jefferson and Madison,
and it's actually written not long
after the constitution goes into effect.
I think it's written
in uh, early 1790. Um,
and at that point Jefferson
had been overseas.
He'd been in France on diplomatic duty,
so he's off in the distance knowing that
they're debating the constitution in
the United States, but he's, he's on
foreign shores, lounging and sell loans,
chatting about philosophical
issues with the French. Meanwhile,
Madison is in the constitutional
convention slaving away
and then he's outside
of it sort of hammering
away at ratification.
So Madison's like climbing over
the issue of the constitution.
Jefferson is kind of looking from afar.
So he writes this letter
to Madison early 1790,
saying that no generation should be
bound to the actions of any previous
generation. It's one of those Jefferson
letters in which he's like, oh good.
An interesting idea because we shared
with you and he starts out with this sort
of idea about generations.
Each generation is a distinct thing.
It should never be bound by the one that
came before and it has his famous line.
Some of you may have heard it already.
Um, the earth belongs to the living right,
that the living should be
controlling things. The Pat,
the dead hand of the past should
not have weight in the presence.
In Typical Jefferson style, he then
calculates what a generation is. Right.
It's not enough to say generations
are distinct. His, well,
how long has it generation anyway,
I will calculate this out. Oh,
and generation is 19
years by Thomas Jefferson,
so he decides a generation is 19
years and then says to Madison,
so every 19 years we
need a new constitution.
Okay,
so Jefferson writing to the
slaving away constitution guy,
because let's do this every 19 years.
I think that would be much fairer.
It wouldn't bind the present to the past.
Now when I read that letter and
then I read Madison's response,
Madison is really tactful.
Madison's a tactical guy and
he's tactful in his response.
But when you look beneath the
surface of Madison's reply,
I always feel like what you see there
is this sustained Howell of disbelief.
You know, like, Oh yeah,
you try that next time teach and then you
come back here and tell me you want to
do that in 19 years. You know? I was like,
no, I'm so, Madison's not happy about it.
But he actually is tactful. And
what he says to Jefferson is, um,
he praises Jefferson's quote. Many
interesting reflections. Sorry.
Thank you. Mr Madison. And
then ads unfortunately quote,
they're not in all respects compatible
with the course of human affairs or in
other words, real people don't
act that way. Like Jefferson.
Nice idea,
not gonna Work and implementation.
That's not like for real life for real
people. It doesn't work but cute idea.
Keep them coming like it's interesting.
We can just keep the conversation going.
We're not doing another constitution
in 19 years. So that's certainly one,
one compromise than Madison
is not willing to sign onto.
But of course the compromises don't
end with the closing of the federal
convention. Creating the constitution
is a major accomplishment now.
It has to be ratified.
There needed to be nine states to
ratify it for it to go into effect.
And each state would have its own
ratifying convention to decide the issue.
Now things would have been difficult
enough if that was the only challenge at
hand if all that they were facing was
ratification debates in the states.
But the fact is there were a slew of
things that could have gone wrong even
before we got to actual ratification.
For one thing,
the Confederation Congress might just
disapprove of the constitution and refuse
to send it on to the states.
It was entirely possible that that the
congress might have said, you know,
you didn't just amend the articles.
He wrote a new constitution.
I'm sorry we don't consider that valid.
Nice try. We're not going to send it on.
And that would have been a
little interesting moment.
It's just as possible that individual
states might refuse to consider it for the
same reason.
And even if some states did consider this
constitution and did decide to ratify
it,
if large influential states like Virginia
or Massachusetts or New York rejected
the constitution,
they're influence might actually compel
other states to follow their example and
vote against it. So all of this
is sort of looming out there.
It's unclear if any of
this is going to happen.
But for those who are really
supporting this new constitution,
they really knew that they had a
pretty big challenge facing them.
If the constitution made it to
the states for ratification.
If the states agreed to consider it,
then they had to worry about the actual
debate over whether this constitution
was adjust. Trustworthy
division of power. Now the,
the first horrible possibility did not
take place and the Confederation Congress
passes on the Constitution to the states
for consideration on September 28th,
1787 but still with the question
of ratification looming,
clearly the fate of the constitution
is left hanging for a good many months.
And I mentioned last time I was
going to go back to Ezra styles, um,
because his diary is useful and wonderful
and I'm going to go right back here to
as a styles, um, just
for a few minutes. Um,
because his diary shows you
one man as certainly one elite,
highly educated, influential man
with very high place friends,
but still one man who is watching events
unfold related to the constitution and
is trying to figure out
what he thinks about them.
He's interested to know what's happening.
He's not sure what he thinks and
he's trying to figure this out.
So one thing that his diary shows is it's
certainly he was intensely interested
in whatever the heck was
going on in Philadelphia.
He didn't know what was
going on in Philadelphia,
but he really wanted to know.
And on June 19th he apparently asked
Yale college seniors to debate the
following question,
whether the states acted
wisely and sending delegates
to the general convention.
Now sitting in Philadelphia,
I didn't know what they're doing,
but Yale students debate
amongst yourselves. Do you
think that was a good idea?
Um,
in November of 1787,
the question that he poses
for Yale College seniors has
changed. Now he says, Yo,
college seniors debate for yourself
whether it is expedient for the states to
adopt the new constitution
in late December,
some of his curiosity gets
satisfied because he actually
gets to spend the night
with Abraham Baldwin,
who had been a delegate in the convention.
So this is his chance.
He's a guy who was there.
He's going to really sort of plug away at
Baldwin, find out what really happened,
and at the end of the evening,
this is what styles wrote in his diary.
I have for,
this is my opinion,
that it is not the most
perfect constitution yet,
number two, that it is a very good one
and that it is advisable to adopted.
However, number three, that though much
of it will be permanent and lasting,
yet much of it will be here after altered
by future revisions and number four,
that the best one remains
yet to investigated.
And then he goes on to add.
When the convention was proposed,
I doubted its expediency. Number
one, he's really a guy for lists,
number one,
because I doubted whether our wisest
men had yet attained light enough to see
and discern the best and what ought
finally to prevail. Number two,
neither did I think the people were ripe
for the reception of the best one if it
could be investigated. And yet
number three, I did not doubt,
but time and future experience would
teach open and lead us to the best one.
And then we've got a much
better one than I expected.
I did a very good one yet my judgment
still remains as before and then he gets
very specific and he says,
I think there's not power enough yet
given to Congress for from government.
So he thinks about that on the one hand.
At the same time he worries that
surrendering too much power to this new
government will end up quote prostrating
the sovereignty of the particular
states. On the one hand he worries that
the president might become quote an
uncontrollable and absolute monarch.
On the other hand he says,
I think first he says, I think the
last as well guarded as possible.
So yeah he might become a monarch but I
think the constitution did as well as it
could to prevent that from happening.
And then goes on to say,
I know not whether it is possible
to vest Congress with laws,
revenues and army and navy
without endangering the
ruin of the interior powers
and liberties of the states and that's a,
that's a long passage for
someone to put in his own diary.
But what's interesting about that to
me is you can see styles going back and
forth. He says it's good, but
there's probably a better one.
It's better than I expected,
but somehow it's not good enough.
It doesn't give enough power to Congress,
but maybe it gives too much power
in the states will be prostrated.
Maybe the president is too powerful,
but if we give some of
that power to Congress,
maybe congress will end up
really destroying the states.
So you can see him there sort of
reasoning through what he thinks about the
constitution and when one way or another
it's boiling down to the balance of
power. Where should power be? He's not
exactly sure where power should be.
He knows it's the issue, but he's not
quite sure how to find his way out
so clearly.
And styles is an example of this.
Although the delegates of
the constitutional convention
had agreed on a new form
of government,
there were certainly not
some huge sweeping national
consensus on the best kind
of government for the new American nation.
So the ratification debates
throughout the states,
except for Rhode Island,
we just not having a debate
but and the rest of the states,
the ones that are actually
having big ratification debates.
These are really real debates and often
these debates focused on the question of
power
as suggested by styles.
One big question along these lines was
how do you divide power between the
national government and the states?
Patrick Henry of Virginia had this to
say about the constitution even before he
got passed its first three words.
Patrick Henry is upset by the first
three words of the constitution.
This doesn't bode well for the
Virginia debate. Henry says,
my political curiosity,
exclusive of my anxious solicitude for
the public welfare leads me to ask who
authorized them to speak the language of
we the people instead of we the states,
states are the characteristic
and the soul of a confederation.
If the states be not the
agents of this compact,
it must be one great
consolidated national government.
Samuel Adams is more concise
but has the same idea. He also,
those first three words,
he can't get past the first three
words he says as I enter the building,
I stumbled at the threshold constitution.
We the people,
we the people like what?
What, what does that,
what does that suggest about
this government? They're
both basically asking what,
what kind of government is this?
It's not a League of states,
the Confederation of States.
It doesn't seem to be about the states.
It appears to be some kind of new powerful
national government linking itself
with the American people and potentially
dismissing the importance of individual
states in the minds of
men like Henry and Adams.
If this was a really federal constitution,
surely the document should begin with we
the states as opposed to we the people,
what they're getting at Henry and Adams
and those kinds of statements is one of
the most unique aspects of
the proposed constitution.
And I think in a sense its most brilliant
compromise and that's the idea of
federalism.
The idea that both the states and the
national government could have large areas
of power with the federal courts,
sort of acting as arbiters about the
limits of state and federal power.
The real brilliance of federalism is that
it suggested that sovereignty could be
divided between two levels of government.
That was an interesting idea.
It was one that many people didn't
believe could actually be put into play,
but it's a,
it's a brilliant suggestion,
a really brilliant compromised
for a population of people
who were worried about
the birth of some kind of tyrannical
centralized national government.
The concept of federalism at least
had some potential. On the other hand,
the idea of nationalism was a
lot more frightening, right?
Nationalism suggests one big national
blob and the obliteration of states or a
styles put at the
prostration of the states.
It's interesting to note
that in the constitution,
the word national does not appear,
and as a matter of fact,
not only is the word national,
not in the original constitution,
but during the debates.
What someone put it in,
somebody else always took it out by, no,
no, we're not talking about national.
It's federal. It's all federal. It's
not the scary big national thing.
It's a federal constitution.
And that's why of course,
the people who are defending
the constitution called
themselves federalists,
not nationalists.
And thus the opponents call
themselves anti federalists.
So federalism is a really brilliant
compromise in this battle over where to
invest power. But obviously it
did not solve all questions.
And for some people it didn't
even solve any of the questions.
The ongoing ratification debate
was actually really fierce.
And since by default we end up sort of
all siding with the federalists. Um,
let's look for a moment at the anti
federalists and the sorts of things that
they were arguing in these debates
throughout all of the states.
For one thing, like everyone else, they
are concerned with the placement of power.
They worry that this new national
executive is going to be a tyrant and
eventually a king. They worry that
state rights, state boundaries,
state constitutions will be violated
by a tyrannical national government.
They fear that the constitution is going
to foster the creation of a standing
army, which everyone of course
believes to be the tool of tyranny.
They fear that some kind of overbearing
aristocracy is going to take over and
repress the common man.
They fear a lack of proper representation.
They fear that they're not going to have
the right sort of a voice or any voice
in this new centralized government.
When you read about these
fears in their original form,
and of course throughout this period
and throughout all of these debates,
you know they're writing newspaper essays,
they're running pamphlets,
they're giving speeches.
This is a,
this is a literal debate in print and in
person and when you read some of these
anti federalists essays and pamphlets,
you can really see how some of them are
directly relatable to the revolution.
Just fought and hopefully one,
I guess in their mind,
maybe it hadn't been one yet because
it depends on what happens with this
government. They're talking about
tyranny, they're talking about monarchy,
they're chucking about violated liberties.
They're talking about aristocracy,
they're talking about unjust
representation. I mean,
you could sort of draw a line and
understand where these fears come from.
Just listen to how some anti federalists
actually expressed these fears.
One writer wrote that the
constitution was quote,
the most odious system of
tyranny that was ever projected.
Patrick Henry, who is always
useful for wonderful quotes, uh,
in the Virginia Convention says that by
giving so much power to a new national
government quote, the tyranny of
Philadelphia, the federal convention,
maybe like the tyranny of
George the third. Okay.
You can't draw a more direct link than
that. Right? Okay. Constitution George,
the third tyranny directly harkening
right back to the revolution.
And for many people these
arguments really rang true.
Now of course in the end,
the federalists proved successful this
despite the fact that they really were
promoting a pretty radical change of
government and there are a good number of
reasons why they're successful.
I'm just going to mention a few here
and one of them in a sense is really
obvious but makes a lot of sense that
it acts in their favor and that is the
federalists are really national minded,
so they're actually thinking beyond the
bounds of their states and it makes them
much more likely to be able to create
some kind of United publicity campaign to
argue on a national level in a way that
perhaps anti-federalists couldn't or
wouldn't.
Also,
one reason why the federalist proves
successful is partly because the anti
federalists don't offer any
alternative to the constitution.
They critique what's there, but they
don't offer an alternative suggestion.
So the debate is criticism and the
federalists defending and countering
criticism and the federalists
defending and countering.
That's a very particular
kind of debate if the,
if the anti federalist could come forward
with another suggestion would have
been a very different kind of debate.
In some ways,
you might argue that the
federalist victory was
something of an anti federalist
default as South Carolina anti federalist,
a Danish Burke put it after the fact.
We had no principal of concert or union.
We were sort of all objecting on our own
and we didn't have any unified campaign
or as Madison put it, I think in
a little bit of an exaggeration,
the Anti federalists quote had no plan,
whatever they look no farther than to
put a negative on the constitution and
return home. Okay, so maybe
that's a little exaggerated,
but in fact there was no obvious concrete
alternative presented by the anti
federalists and that really was a
fundamental weakness in their position.
This does not mean however,
that there were no good arguments against
the constitution and the best proof of
that is the federalist essays,
which you're going to be reading this
week because those essays aren't just
explaining the constitution,
they're defending the constitution and
they're defending it against the sea of
fears and accusations and all these
sort of wild ideas floating around about
what might happen or what's implied or
what's suggested or what's allowable in
this new government.
The federalist essays where Hamilton's
idea and Hamilton invited his nationalist
buddy James Madison to join him in the
effort and they also invited John Jay to
take part in.
John Jay ended up getting sick,
so he wrote a few essays and
then he dropped out. So, um,
as I'm sure you well know, most of them
are written by Madison and Hamilton.
The federalists was not the only
printed defense of the constitution.
There are lots of them. There's obviously,
as I said, it's a big print debate,
but the federalists was something that
was written with really big ambitions
because its authors really,
essentially we're creating a broad,
comprehensive step by step
defense of the constitution.
And they really hoped that by swaying
the state of New York in favor of
ratification,
maybe they would bring other states
like Virginia along in its wake.
The essays were all signed Publius.
The authors all wrote under the same
pseudonym because they actually wanted the
essays not to seem like
the crafty arguments of to
really leading nationalists
were going to say anything to get
us to sign on to the constitution.
They wanted to suggest that these were
just even handed rational ideas that were
sort of generally out in the
public sphere. Now, of course,
among insiders,
people figured out who the authors were,
even though supposedly no one's supposed
to know it's Boodley who can that be?
People figured it out pretty quickly
and sometimes the authors helped people
along.
And there's an anecdote about Hamilton.
I went digging to see if I could find
ultimate verification and I can't find the
ultimate verification, but I'm
going to offer it anyway. Um,
because there's a suppose
witness to the story,
but people aren't sure whether to
believe the witness at any rate.
Hamilton supposedly,
the day before his fatal duel with
Aaron Burr paid a call on a friend,
good 18th century named Egbert Vinson.
He went to visit Edward Benson,
who was a lawyer and supposedly one of
Benson's law clerks answered the door,
said that he would go find Benson, walked
off to find Benson. And as he came back,
he said he saw Hamilton
in Benson's library,
put something in a book and put the book
up on the shelf. And the clerk said,
Mr. Benson is not here. And
Allison said, thank you and left.
So of course the guy's like,
I knew it. That was right.
So he goes over to the shelf
and he pulls down the book.
He wants to see what it is and supposedly
what it was is a piece of paper in
Hamilton's and writing in which he'd
written all of the federalist essays that
were his, you know, supposedly the
night before the dual when he's like,
got my checklist of things I better do
in case I died tomorrow. Number One,
get credit for federalist
essays. No, you know,
it's unclear whether that
actually happened or didn't
happen that the guy, the,
the fellow who saw it in later years
said he did see it and said he saw the
piece of paper and said
the piece of paper,
at some point it was given to
the New York public library,
but then nobody quite knows where it
is and the New York public library. Um,
so it's unclear whether it
really happened, people that,
some people at the time insisted it really
did. Um, whether or not it really did.
The fact is that actually the people who
wrote it did care about it and didn't
care about which ones they wrote.
Um,
and we don't entirely know who wrote which
in some cases we know summer Hamilton
essays and Summer Madison essays.
And then there were somewhere it's
blurrier and historians argue, you know,
give one guy credit or the
other guy credit over who,
and I think that's partly,
well,
partly because they were rushing,
but also partly because in some cases
they probably were working together on
some or sharing things.
The humbling thing to remember when you
read the federalist this week and this,
this actually should really mean
something to, to any student,
is that many of them are first drafts.
Those are rough drafts.
That just makes me want to cry
as a writer. It's like, oh,
why can't my rough drafts look
like that? These guys were, were,
were writing for newspapers,
so they were in a hurry sometimes,
literally like dashing something off and
getting it to the newspaper immediately.
So they're writing these in a hurry
there and don't have time for a lot of
revision. That to me is, is
in amazingly humbling thought.
All told there were 85
federalists essays. Um,
as I said,
they're published in New York newspapers.
The thought is they're going to sway the
New York ratification debate and they
appear between October,
1787 and may of 1788 and then later in
June of 1788 they get put out in book
form. And then obviously they
migrate wherever they migrate to.
Lots of other people read the federalist
now as suggested by its title.
The federalist,
while it did demonstrate a lot of
things about the new constitution,
it did have one overriding argument,
and that was the benefits of
federalism, right? Not Nationalism.
And they're sure to stress that
throughout all of the essays,
we're not talking about
nationalism. Federal, federal
states are still important.
The subtext of the common
component of the federalist essays,
a federal government would energize
the government without prostrating the
states or trampling on the
American people. That's the
compromise, a federalism.
And as I mentioned at some point earlier
in an earlier lecture to demonstrate
just how badly this government
needed to be energized.
The federalists essay show again and
again the disaster that would reign if the
articles of confederation were allowed
to continue and at some point I did talk
about the sort of acts job that the
federalists essays due on the articles of
confederation.
They really want to,
because they have to prove
that the articles are so
bad that of course this new
constitution, it's the
perfect thing. It makes sense.
You have to move in this direction.
So in New York and elsewhere,
the ratification debates roar on
state's proceeding at different paces.
But there is one thing that emerged from
these debates on the part of the Anti
federalists and it's actually is a
specific suggestion on their part specific
idea about something that has to be
there basically throughout the states.
One thing that anti federalists
consistently demanded with some kind of
guarantee of personal liberties,
some kind of a declaration of rights
like those that existed in many state
constitutions.
Something that would protect personal
liberties in the same document that seemed
to be investing this new government
with so much power. So in essence,
the anti federalist want a bill of rights.
Now,
from our vantage point,
a bill of rights just seems like an
unquestionably good thing, right?
We love our bill of rights.
The bill of rights is good.
Why would the federalists
not want a bill of rights?
But the problem is some federalists did
have problems with this idea of a bill
of rights.
For one thing,
they claimed that the entire constitution,
by providing a well framed government
that had checks and balances that
government by election,
in a sense,
you could argue that that document was
so framed and the government was so
checked and balanced that it was in
and of itself a sort of bill of rights.
It was a controlled government.
They also said the federal government
has a numerated powers in this document.
So in other words,
a power that is not given to the
government is not owned by the government.
Why do we need a bill of rights
saying, Whoa, we need to protect power?
Of the press.
We haven't given power of the press to
the national government so why do we need
some lead to mention
it in a bill of rights?
Some federalist even argued that if we
start to write things down like put doc,
you put rights into writing,
we might actually imply something bad
might actually imply like if we tried to
define the freedom of press freedom
of religion and put it into words,
maybe the implication will be that
in some way or another the national
government actually does have
some power over those things.
Maybe once we get into the sea of rights,
we might lead people to be able to
conclude things about that government down
the road that we might
not want them to conclude.
But the anti federalist had a pretty
powerful argument in favor of a bill of
rights.
It was a multi leveled argument,
but one part of it was particularly
hard to argue with and that is any
Republican government,
any small r Republican government ought
to do everything that it could do to
keep it citizens aware of their rights,
including something like listing them
as amendments to the constitution.
In other words, the federalist
say, well I never republic.
The people need to know their rights,
they need to have them in writing.
So of course we should have a bill of
rights so that the American public knows
what their rights are.
In the end,
it was only with the promise that a list
of rights would be amended and added to
the constitution that it
was ultimately ratified.
And so one by one the states debated
and then over time decided to ratify the
constitution. Um, I think again,
as with so many things about this
period and the constitution debate,
we don't tend to think of it as a
real fight or debate or controversy.
We sort of see things turning along
and we imagined ratification of the
constitution equals a bunch of guys in a
room signing pieces of paper. Like hug,
ratify the end. Now let's have
a government. But in fact,
people were really anxiously
watching this and curious,
our state's going to ratify how many
will ratify? Is this going to happen?
Won't it happen?
What happens if only half of them ratify?
This is something that people
all over the United States,
we're watching and wondering what was
going to happen here as freestyles helps
us out. One more time. Um,
because he put in his diary every time
he heard that a state had ratified the
constitution, though in the midst
of everything else in his diary,
you'll see like, um, on January 9th, 1788,
he writes that a Korea raced from Hartford
to new haven and made the entire trip
in a mere hour and six minutes,
which actually since it takes what,
like 45 minutes by car to go to Hartford,
an hour and six minutes,
it's pretty good for a horse,
I think.
So that guy really raised to announce
two new haven that Connecticut had
ratified the constitution. Right. And
he puts that down and he's clearly,
it was impressed with
the speed of the writer.
On February 11th new haven gets the news
that Massachusetts ratified styles puts
this in his diary and he adds bells were
rung throughout the city and Canon were
discharged.
So now clearly Connecticut has signed on,
they're watching to see who else is
signing on and when someone else does sign
on,
there's a celebration at the end of June.
Styles noted that at about
one 30 in the afternoon. And,
and I love when they know what the
precise time, cause then you know,
it's something they believe to be
significant. At one 30 this afternoon,
new haven received the news that New
Hampshire had ratified and that New
Hampshire is the ninth state.
So what that means is that now the
constitution could go into effect and it
styles described it.
As soon as the news arrived,
the four bills and the city were set a
ringing and the federal flag displayed
and federal federal discharges of Canyon.
What does it actually a federal discharge
of cannon? I don't know what a federal,
I never typed that out without stopping
to think what a federal discharge of
Canada,
but there was a federal discharge of
Canon and rejoicing general rejoicing in
new haven like the constitution has
kicked in. Thank you. New Hampshire.
Meanwhile, throughout this period style
still had Yale college seniors debating
constitutional issues.
If you are not interested in politics
at this point at Yale College,
you were in deep trouble.
Um,
he had them debate whether it had been
better to refer the new constitution to
ratification by town meetings or a
plurality of personal votes of all the
Freeman of the United States.
Now that's kind of interesting actually.
That's kind of a radical thing for him
to ask the students to debate or whether
the president of Congress,
president of Congress,
the president ought to be visited with
an independent power of commanding the
American army.
If you're curious about what other things
styles has people debating in addition
to random constitutional issues.
I just have a little sampling here to
give you a sense of what it would have
been like to be a senior at
Yale college in 1788 and 1789.
Um, they debated whether the breaking
up of the Roman Empire by the GAAPS and
vandals was prejudicial to
the progress of literature.
Kod doing that one day and
then the next day like, uh, no,
let's talk about the president.
Um,
they debated whether the
scriptures are divinely inspired,
whether good policies ever inconsistent
with justice and whether all mankind
descended from Adam. Okay. That's,
so that's a wide ranging bunch
of things they're debating. Um,
I love the fact that style's always
puts that in his diary, you know,
so it's actually fascinating just to read
through and see what students were set
to discuss at a given time.
Okay.
So we've seen a national
debate over a new constitution.
We've seen a debate taking place between
people who by no means had an absolute
consensus about what kind of
government should be put into place.
Given that this was a national debate,
what does it show us about the
state of the nation at the time?
What does it really suggest about
the new nation and its principles?
Well,
certainly for one thing,
underneath all of the disagreement
and the wrangling and the arguing,
there was some consensus.
So certainly both federalists and
anti federalists agreed that I,
small r Republican government
was the general aim and goal.
A government based on popular
sovereignty on the will of the people,
a government that place the ultimate
power in the hands of the people.
So that's a general consensus.
I'm going to talk in a
moment about what that means,
but certainly in a general way
people could agree on that.
Americans also could generally agree that
this was an experiment in government,
that it was something unique,
that they were experimenting in the
possibility of having people sit down and
deliberately create,
adjust government,
grounded on the rights and will of the
populace and to to communicate this,
to get this across. Um, I'm
going to read something.
I don't think I've read this before.
Have I?
I don't think I've read
the first paragraph or the
first couple sentences from
the first federalist essay.
I went digging back in the other lectures
and I don't think I've done it yet and
if I have, you're going to have to listen
to it twice. But I don't think I have.
Um, and I tend to read these couple
sentences in a lot of my classes, um,
because I think they really capture
this idea about experimentation that's
looming over what they're
doing at the time.
The sense that they really
are deciding something major,
not just in the constitution
that they're creating,
but also in the process by
which they're creating it.
That the fact that they're deliberating,
debating and then creating
and it's stepping back to
allow it to go into effect.
That also is something that
they see as major. So this is,
this is from within the first paragraph,
a federalist number one by Hamilton.
It has been frequently remarked that
it seems to have been reserved to the
people of this country by their conduct
and example to decide the important
question whether societies of men are
really capable or not of establishing good
government from reflection and choice
or whether they are forever destined to
depend for their political
constitutions on accident and force.
The crisis at which we are arrived may
with propriety be regarded as the era in
which that decision is to be made and a
wrong election of the part we shall act,
may deserve to be considered as
the general misfortune of mankind.
Okay.
UHMM like that's a big statement.
He's literally saying the United
States is deciding for all time.
If you can sit and deliberate and
create a just government or not,
and if we do something stupid,
the answer would appear
to be not for all time.
So this experiment is
not just an experiment,
but it's one that to people at
the time actually means something.
They feel that they're proving something
in this experiment that they're
undertaking. It has real
consequences. Now, that said,
of course, even with the
ratification of the constitution,
all kinds of questions are still looming
about exactly how this experiment was
going to play out or indeed
if it would survive at all,
and wrapped up in this question about
what's going to happen with the government
is a deeper question about whether the
promise of the revolution is actually
going to be fulfilled. The revolution
has all of this promise attached to it.
There's all of this debate about how
to bring that kind of promise to life.
Here's one try.
It's a constitution.
We're going to put it into effect and
people now have to step back and see if
it's going to work and many,
many people that are absolutely not
convinced that it's going to fulfill all
that promise that was
unleashed by the revolution.
It's one thing to assign power in a
document and it's another thing to really
bring that document to life.
If you think about our constitution,
it's a pretty short document. It's
pretty brief. It's, it's a framework.
It doesn't go into lots of detail,
so there's a lot of things that had to
be fleshed out and worked out once that
government went into effect
and in Thursday's lecture.
I'm going to touch on some of that.
I'm going to talk a little bit about how
this begins to play out in the 70s and
nineties and what that suggests about
the legacy of the revolution overall.
I will stop there.
I will see you on Thursday or last class.